[Music]
today's question comes from denia in
florida
she said i'll be getting married soon to
a man who is also previously divorced we
are 55 and 45. he has property that his
parents left him that he would like to
go to his children upon his death i
don't disagree but we are struggling
with a couple of issues is the best way
to handle this to have a prenup
agreement regarding the property also i
struggle with the fact that the place
that will be our home doesn't really
feel like my home i worry that i'll
spend the rest of my life improving the
property only to have zero ownership of
it when my husband passes i'm not sure
how we deal with both of these things
that's a great question
there's a there's definitely a dilemma
here she wants ownership but he wants it
to go to his children instead of her
well she's the verbage that she's using
is not greedy and grabbing no but she
makes a valid point she's only 45 years
old she lives there 30 or 40 years
and they fix up the house with money
that's also hers over the years and then
it's all gone that feels unfair and not
only that he dies and she's 55 years old
has to move
for what's been her home for 10 years at
that point or 15 years or whatever the
number is right and so she's got some
valid points obviously he does as well
um because this is family property and
he would like it to stay
in the family his parents left him that
property so that does put it in
interesting light
well here's the thing
okay
uh here's the here's what's here's
what's the
argument in my mind
it's as if the past is arguing with the
future
it's a good way to put it
and
what are we going to place more value on
this marriage relationship
or making sure this house goes to these
kids
so i'm trying to think
what i would do if i were in his shoes
and i had some property
um and how do we honor her and take care
of her i'm not sure
uh a prenup is obviously in order
a will
in conjunction with prenup so that
everything is laid out but i don't know
how to make sure she's taken care of if
this property turns around and goes to
them in terms of a a place to live and b
recouping and really you've got the
emotional loss if she lives in that home
20 years it's more hers
it is those kids yeah and i guess i
question why he wants to leave it to the
kids other than this is family property
and i wanted to stay in the family but
is she not family that's what she's
feeling like you know she's the step
mother the you know it's a
cinderella syndrome right um in that
sense she's not the evil stepmother but
i mean
um
i mean to the property it doesn't seem
like it's it's all that you know what i
think you've got to decide what you
value here
what do you value more he needs to
decide what does he value more
marriage and the future with this lady
uh if so i think they need to go buy
another house
that the two of them own together
and they can keep this house and rent it
and it can go to the
yeah i wouldn't live there i wouldn't
make my home there it feels weird to
choose the kids or the wife that just
feels like it's going to be
uncomfortable
and i i think if you want to leave the
if you want to keep the property in the
family
but she can't make a home there
because it's temporary
yeah
um it's never going to be hers and it's
going to affect their relationship
yeah so you just can't place the
stuff above the relationship the
relationship you know we arrange the
stuff around the relationship not the
relationship around the stuff
that's what i'm doing yeah
what is it you wanna what is it your
value the kids are gonna be okay i mean
you can leave the money there's a lot of
ways to bless the kids but it feels like
this feels like this house is somewhat
up on an idol yeah it symbolizes
something yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna rent
it out or i'm gonna sell it
and i will leave it to them
in the will
and it can be in a prenup that's fine no
big deal and i'm but i'm not going to
live in it i'm not going to make my
future wife my future life
live there besides that she may not want
to live where his other wife was
that's true yeah you know that that also
can be weird whether she passed away or
whether it was a divorce we don't know
but um that can be also weird there's a
lot of ingredients that could create a
recipe for resentment here and that's
what i don't want yeah i'm not living in
that house
i'm not living it i think that's the
answer that's just me and i'm trying to
figure it it's a very
sticky question yeah there's no clear
answer weird i don't know exactly what
to do with it's not you're right it
doesn't it doesn't come to mind you go
oh that's the answer because a prenup
doesn't solve
her no it only solves him
a will doesn't solve her it only solves
him
desires and problems uh you you could
even put in the prenup or in the will
that any monies any repairs or
improvements done to the home
are reimbursed to her
upon his death out of the life insurance
or something else so you can make her
right financially but you can't make it
right that she lived there for 20 years
it becomes her home and then it's not
there's a true emotion she's not got
control of her own home yeah
and that's just not gonna that's not
gonna work for me yeah it's a valid
question yeah good stuff good stuff hey
thanks for the thanks for sending that
in that that's a that's a wake-up call
right there so uh is this a good idea
prenups oh yeah in general we say don't
do them that's right the exception is if
you've got a real high net worth and
you've got a lot of assets and things
going on that's where we go okay maybe
we need to look at this through a
different lens yeah because
not because of the spouse in all my
years of doing financial coaching the
potential spouse is not the problem it's
their crazy family yes
people think that they feel entitled
uncle louie feels entitled because his
niece married a wealthy guy or his
nephew married a wealthy lady whatever
it is right and so
it's just there's weird crap out there
in these families man and so
and if you just go if you just put up a
wall and you go up there's prenup and
there's you don't get anything so
and i recommend it just for clarity and
for that now i don't recommend a prenup
where there's very small assets i mean
it needs to be
an extreme difference like one person
has almost nothing one person has two
million dollars or more something like
that it's not you know like one lady
called and said or emailed and said uh
my boyfriend wants a prenup to um for
his classic car
oh wow i'm like don't marry him
he looks like he likes his car more than
you yikes you know this guy's not
marriage material he's he's weird
so yeah you know i just want to tell my
daughter if they come in you know my son
if they said no the they want to prenup
for this little tiny stupid butt 20 000
50 000 item that's just silly yeah so
it's got to be we're talking you know a
few million dollars in assets and
they make just an average salary we want
to make sure that those assets are
protected from crazy yeah yeah and this
right here is
has got a different element to it that
is trying to
make sure that the
the family assets are passed through to
the kids is all that's all they were
doing there that's different than i've
got to protect my assets from you that
i'm making this person marrying you you
know that kind of thing we don't really
have to protect them from you george
you're not i hope not you're not gonna
i'm not a danger to anyone you're not a
danger not even i mean a little girl
could take me in a fight so you're safe
you're safe out there guys don't worry
oh man
not true thank you thank you for the
vote
i've seen you you're vicious you're a
vicious i'm scrappy you're scrappy
you're scrappy